[Music]
welcome everybody to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast i am your
fearful host professor brian keating of
the university of california san diego
and today's guest is none other than one
of the most controversial but also
unifying to others
uh figures in popular culture today and
that's ben shapiro editor emeritus of
the daily wire and host of the ben
shapiro show
then talks nearly as fast as i do and we
want to cover a tremendous amount of
ground on today's podcast
and i took away three main things from
this podcast including what ben is
really like
outside of his media empire what he'd be
doing
if he wasn't doing these podcasts and
other
activities that he's so deeply involved
with and who his dream guest is he's had
me on a show
so he can scratch that off his bucket
list but who would he most like to have
on
that answer to that question truly
shocked me and i believe you'll be
shocked as well
it totally came to me out of left field
so uh set sit back and enjoy the ride
with one of america's most controversial
but interesting
figures and i hope you enjoyed this as
much as i did
uh well today it is a great pleasure to
welcome
none other than the little known very
very uh
very little known and little followed
ben shapiro author of the brand new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps uh
ben how are you sheltering today uh well
i mean
here in california we can't go inside
because of covet and we can't go outside
because of the smoke so i'm just
standing in the doorway all day and if
there's an earthquake we're set we're
good
yeah you're safe just like in the old
days you know if there was atomic blast
just duck and cover under your desk it'd
be fine
um so as you may know the podcast the
into the impossible podcast that i host
is very non-political we don't get into
anything political because i think we
have too much politics in the world we
have
uh too much you know division and
polarization and not the good kind of
astronomical polarization so
i just want to prepare the listeners for
30 minutes of abject silence so
we'll just sit there we'll stare at each
other i was going to say dude you picked
that you picked the wrong guest i mean
uh so i want to start with you uh you're
known for so many things we're going to
talk about the book hopefully
uh we're also going to talk about uh the
many enthusiasms that you have
outside of politics because i think you
know i always say there's no red
constellations there's no blue comets
uh no one ever wakes up i hate astronomy
you know in fact today there's a big
there's big breaking news about possible
discovery of
of evidence for life on the planet venus
uh which is a place that's a little
hotter than
the valley where i think you are right
now um but i want to begin with how does
ben shapiro view himself
so if an alien or one of our listeners
or uh or to wake you up
three in the morning and ask you are you
a podcaster
are you an author are you a pundit what
is ben shapiro to venture bureau
uh well i mean first of all a
magnificently handsome gentleman i mean
i think you have to begin with the good
looks
that's actually the entire thing maybe
just just in just an incredible apollo
esque specimen of humanity the finest
that that
world has to offer uh aside from that i
mean primarily
i am a husband and a dad and that is
that is how i
identify myself that's what i spend most
of my time worrying about and doing
and then somebody who i hope is engaged
in the world of ideas i spend
an awful lot of time trying to read on
all sides of various issues and i have a
broad range of
interests i hope that i'm trying to give
impetus to people to make better
decisions in their own lives and to
do things that are meaningful to them i
think if i have one
giant message whether it's political or
life it's it's that
most of what is in your hands is in your
hands i think that the biggest question
in life right now and this is true
politically but it's also
personally is whether you decide to take
responsibility for your own actions and
improve your own life
uh and if the answer is yes then you're
likely to be successful and if the
answer is no you're likely to be
unsuccessful it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be problems that are
outside
your control but i think that the
biggest question we all have to ask
ourselves in a free society
is how much responsibility we wish to
take so if i'm an advocate for that
position
chiefly then i'll be happy with that so
it's interesting you mentioned that
and uh and not being a podcaster you're
followed by millions of people
you're known for your opinions et cetera
but you you essentially key into your
responsibility as a husband and a father
and this takes us somewhere where i
wasn't planning to go for a while for
the next and
until about 90 minutes from now but i'll
start it now
uh just kidding the uh the question i
want to ask is in the in the bible the
famous story of adam
and eve when they come up um it said
that you know god created
uh eve because it was not good for man
to be alone
and of course that means humanity and
basically men and women
uh i want to ask you what matured you
more what caused you to be more mature
uh getting married or or having or
having children because
if it's not good to be alone it would
seem to me call the homer as they might
say
you should have as many kids as possible
so which is more important to you
uh you know or which was more maturing
to maturation part of your maturation
process getting married or having
children
um i mean i don't want to borrow from
from sort of
an area where you are significantly more
versed than i am but
it sort of feels like raqqa it feels
like rocket stages uh it'd be
it would be you know one builds on
another uh i would say that that
escaping in maturity requires
uh you to realize that you are not the
only person in the universe and that you
have to put somebody else's interest
first that would be getting married
but then realizing there's an entire
another generation that you have to pass
things along to that you have to
structure your life in such a way as to
provide a home for values
uh that you really do have to build as
as we in the jewish community say
buy net money but you throw you have to
build a believing household um
when people talk about building a
household i don't think they think about
it
you know seriously enough with the
language actually means it's not just
that you
create a household in which to live you
have to decide how to build you have to
decide which materials to use you have
to decide how to structure that
household
uh and that means you have to decide
where the doors go where the windows go
how exactly people are gonna live within
that household
and that means structuring your own
values you have to build yourself in
order to build the household and i think
that
having kids uh yeah for me having kids
was the culmination of a thought process
that begins when you choose to get
married
so i'm of the view and i've made this
clear before that i think that if people
want to have successful marriages you
have to decide to get married before you
meet the person you're going to marry
mainly because if you meet the person
you're going to marry and then you kind
of fall into marriage
you may have had a very different job
description when you met than you do
when you get married
when you're looking to get married then
you're looking for something very
different you're looking for somebody to
build that house with somebody who has
the same values
you do whereas if you fall in love with
somebody it may be that now you have to
kind of jerry-rig the structure
that you want to live inside because
you've already you know met somebody and
you've already
built a life with this person that was
kind of accidental uh so
for me it was it was deciding to get
married followed by getting married
which means that you start to build that
house and then
filling that house with children and
then adjusting the house on the fly is
is sort of how i would think of
you know the maturation process
yeah i always say it's it's possible to
get to be single
and be selfish and just think about
yourself it's probably possible to be
married and be selfish although not for
super long because it probably won't
last that long
but but then you have to start thinking
about the you know your moods and taking
care of another person
potentially but it's impossible to have
children for selfish reasons i mean
nobody says at three in the morning i'm
really getting too much sleep i i really
like to change some diapers i mean
besides me
i like to get the experience with dark
matter you know it's very inaccessible
otherwise
uh but uh but that brings up a question
i had for you is sort of
how you structured your life it seems
very methodical i mean you've been
writing since you were 16 or
maybe even younger you started ucla or
bitter rivals to the north
and uh and did you have a plan for for
how you would go about life because
we i'm a pilot people know that um you
know and it's often said
even in you know disparate fields like
chess or whatever
a bad plan beats no plan did you have a
plan and
looking back was it did your life kind
of unfold to that to that plan according
to plan or totally randomly
so i would say that i had a long term
plan like if you had asked me when i was
16 what i wanted to do it would actually
kind of look a lot like like what i have
right now thank god
but i i left a lot of avenues open as to
how to achieve that plan
so i think that short-term planning can
be very very difficult because
they're just too many contingencies but
long-term planning allows you to to
realize that there's play in the joints
as you move toward
uh you know what what you're attempting
to do and so my entire career i've i've
always thought
keeping windows open having the
lifeboats ready is is a good strategy
uh and and then you know being able to
take advantage of opportunities as they
arise as opposed to you lock yourself
into one path and now you're path
dependent if this doesn't work you're
kind of stuck
uh i've always you know tried to keep a
long-term goal in mind
and then be open to the opportunities in
front of me and try to see how those
opportunities can kind of move back and
forth
but in general toward that long-term
goal and to that end do you have a
a daily routine uh how do you structure
it on a tactical level a daily level
versus the long-term strategic level
that you just laid out what's the
balance
well i mean coveted killed it because i
had a daily routine
and then my children don't go to school
anymore and they're home all the time
and my wife the doctor
i can't even uh she's on maternity leave
and she's continued to be on maternity
leave throughout this so
life has radically shifted since covet
but before covet i had a pretty solid
daily routine
i'd wake up in the morning i would
generally wake up with the dawn because
my kids wake me up i would take care of
the kids until
my wife woke up um i'd make breakfast
for them kind of review the news on my
phone while i was doing that
um and then i would as soon as my wife
could take over i would go and do my
morning prayers
then i would go into work do do my work
the podcast maybe some writing come home
eat lunch take a couple of hours out to
work out
and do some other work you know so
writing or prepping for the next day
and then it was take care of the kids
for several hours uh and then at night
after the kids go to bed usually that's
when i start to prep for the show the
next day
and then it's relaxing away for a couple
of hours so it's pretty balanced life i
would say
but and and with with kind of defined
areas i do think that it's important to
define
how you focus your time the biggest
mistake that i've made and i think
people generally make
is the belief that you're good at
multitasking nobody is good at
multitasking it's just not something
people are good at
you need dedicated amounts of time in
order to focus and that means that
um there's a very funny uh but but i
think true
statement that i'm remember which famous
writer said this where somebody
asked them can i have five minutes of
your time he said no he said well it's
just five minutes he said right but it's
not five minutes it's
it's at least 20 because you asking me
the question has now taken me out of my
routine for a certain amount of time
then i have to actually give you my
attention
then after you leave i have to spend a
certain amount of time getting back into
my routine so
there's no such thing as taking five
minutes out to do something you really
do have to break your time down
into significant chunks yeah that brings
up another point your friend sam harris
has said at least on his podcast
that uh it's actually not time that's
the most precious quantity it's
attention right we all have time to
watch enough cat videos you know at
least
speaking personally i'm not afraid to
admit that uh but but it's really the
attention that you just spoke about it's
taking away attention
and i wonder when you look into your you
know your your children's face your
newborn
and you say basically i'm weighing this
decision you know to to grow my
following to grow the daily wire to grow
your podcast your audience or radio
you're effectively taking time away and
i struggle with that too
how do you struggle with the guilt you
know because you you are kind of a
victim of your own success
and it has to come at some level at the
cost at the expense of
of attention at least to your family so
how do you balance that mentally are you
how do you how do you weigh those kind
of opposite disparate forces
so i mean the good news for me is that
i've been really able to build a
terrific team here with my business
partner jeremy boring
at daily wire so i've been able to to
really delegate a lot of responsibility
to people who are better at these things
than i am so i don't run my own social
media sort of presence i mean i
obviously tweet and i put things on
facebook but that's not a major part of
of my day uh and uh i'm i'm sort of
involved in the strategic level but
because our company is now so large we
have over 100 employees i'm able to
really delegate a lot and that means
that when i focus i focus in very
specifically on what it is that i need
to do
and then i'm able to you know pitch in
at home a lot and but it's been true for
a while i've always made it a top
priority
to ensure that i'm there a lot for my
kids i've been very involved with my
kids even though i work a lot
yeah for for you know since since they
were born my daughter is now six
um i was actually you know sort of the
chief parental influence until probably
the last year and a half when my wife
finished residency so for a long time my
wife
was actually doing a lot more work on an
hourly basis than i was because she was
in medical residency i would bring the
kids to visit her at the hospital she
would duck out for 15 minutes come down
kiss the kids i would take them home and
get them ready for bed
uh so i've always made this like a real
priority and that comes from my own
parents who made it a real priority
particularly my father who was actually
home a lot more than my mom when i was
growing up
um but uh i'm lucky i've been able to
structure my days in such a way that
again i wake up with my kids i'm able to
spend time with them before school
um by the time they get home from school
i've typically worked out
a lot of my day already i'm able to take
a break with them until they go to bed
and then after they go to bed i'll do a
little bit more work so
i'd say if anybody has suffered from
lack of time and attention it's probably
uh marriage but that's what happens when
you have kids once you have kids then
it's like okay the adults have to take
the head
that's right so uh you know speaking of
well before we get to that i want to
talk about your mom
specifically but um not your on your on
the playground level your mom
i got some your mama jokes for you ben
uh no seriously uh before we get there
uh i have a question for you so do you
do anything to keep grounded uh like
meditation do you do any meditation as
part of your ritual
besides prayer which is obviously
meditative right i mean uh prayer you
know
is that i will say i'm not very good at
it uh i i need to get better
at prayer uh probably that the closest i
get to
daily relaxation is just working out
which i try to do daily
uh for an hour probably uh and that's a
good time for me to sort of chill out
and relax and i'll listen to podcasts or
listen to music while i work out
and i find that pretty calming but aside
from praying which as i say i'm i'm not
particularly good at because i think to
be really good at prayer you have to be
able to as you say focus and
and i mean as you know orthodox jews uh
we started off with pretty short prayers
and then they got longer and longer and
longer so it turns out that now
in order to get through chakras the
morning prayer you have to bully your
way through
you know 75 pages of hebrew text so i
get through it pretty quickly
but that also does not help in terms of
like okay you know
if you're meditating you're meditating
on one thing and you're being on that
one thing for a particularly long period
of time
and just getting through that much text
is not super conducive to that yeah i
was going to ask you i had a live stream
with rabbi david wolpe
from sinai temple last week and i asked
him you know i said
there's famous sayings you know a jew
can be angry at god and drew can be
happy with god
but a jew can't be without god i mean
the very word israel means you know
wrestles with god which implies that at
least you take god seriously
but my question to him and i guess i'll
make it to you too although i suspect
from what you just said it might not be
answerable by you is can you be a jew
without prayer i mean i relate so much
more to judaism through intellectual
through talmud study whatever
than i do to it through prayer it's just
very difficult for me with the high
holidays coming up
uh this week how do you how do you what
do you think do you think you can be a
jew without prayer or
or do you have to work at it especially
because it's hard for you
so i mean i i should be working at it
more and i'll admit to uh to a certain
amount of laziness that has set in uh
and that's something that i i definitely
need to work on but
i think that we have to separate off a
couple things can you be a jew without
commandments or can you be a jew without
being good at praying
so the reason that i pray is not because
i like praying or because i'm good at it
the reason that i pray is because i'm
commanded to right because that is one
of them is both
uh so i do not think that you can be a
jew without adhering to commandments
that
you personally don't enjoy i think that
that one definitely is requisite
um but can you be a jew without being
good at praying
sure i think that i think that you can
doesn't mean that you're fulfilling your
capacity as
as you know i'm sure i'm not um but it
but i agree with you i mean
the stuff where i tend to get a lot of
meaning in judaism um is
the is the study is the reading is the
insights
um maybe some of the social stuff
although i'm not super social as a human
being
um so i'm the kind of guy who when i go
to shoal
i will you know i tend to dive in ahead
and then i will usually have a safer
i'll usually have a book with me
and i'll start reading the book and i'll
you know spend 20 minutes reading the
book and i generally feel like
on an emotional level and on
intellectual level i tend to get more
out of that than the prayer but
it's probably just because i you know
need to put more work into my prayer
which i'll
as i say freely acknowledge yeah that's
good to have at least one thing to work
on in the new year
um so uh the next question i have for
you actually revolves around
commandments so if you you could
convince
uh jeremy boring who you call the god
king or whatever uh
or if you were god uh let's say uh which
of the commandments
would you get rid of and you can't say
adultery okay you can't say adult
i wasn't going to honestly that one i
don't find particularly troubling yeah
no no that one that one's actually
like there's some that that there are
some that obviously don't make tons of
sense that one seems to make a fair bit
of sense to me uh the the
um you know uh all the strictures around
kosher
are can be pretty difficult particularly
if you travel a lot as you know
uh so those some of those are
particularly difficult honestly i think
that a lot of the commandments is
originally articulated in the bible are
a lot less
onerous than some of the rabbinic
practice that's been stacked on top
right there's this old jewish joke that
moses comes around you know that you
know
it's now several thousand years since
the revelation at sinai and the jews
decide they've had enough this deal has
been bad for them they decide that
they're going to
uh get out of the deal so they bring all
the books they bring all this for him
they bring all the talmud they bring
everything over to mount sinai and they
say
to uh and they say to god and moses we
don't want this anymore we want to give
all this back
and moses said what is all this i gave
you five books
right and uh i think that there is uh
you know well while i adhere to the
commandments there's certainly some
truth there i mean it's become very
in some ways obstrues and and codified
that's not unusual that happens in
virtually every religion or legal system
um but there are certain aspects that
are
that are you know difficult and onerous
uh first honestly i don't find
living an orthodox lifestyle
particularly onerous generally i mean
listen i live in a nice
big jewish urban area there are lots of
them in the united states
i can get good restaurants i need good
food my wife's a good cook
um i like shabbat i think shabbat is a
godsend um
literally so that's you know that that
doesn't bother me too much
in terms of the commandments that you
know i think are are
over overdone a lot of that would be
arguments
that you know i would say that many
modern orthodox jews and
and some of uh the jts conservatives
have had for a long time like his
chicken meat kind of stuff
and then conversely are there any
commandments that you would add if you
were
exercising your deistic propensities
uh i feel like we have plenty okay to be
honest with you i feel like i feel like
the 613 which is the minimum and then
the several thousand that in
practicality actually are added on top i
feel like
we don't have a dearth of commandments i
feel like we're on top of that yeah we
have enough yeah i always say you know
people say i have trouble keeping the
commandments i say did you sleep with
your mother-in-law recently and they
said no and i'm like all right you're
you're part way there you know your
point you know zero one five percent of
the way there
um so you always say uh one of your uh
you know key
you know characteristic lines is
turnabout is fair play
and i wanna uh start talking about the
book for a little bit this is of course
your what a sixth seventh book now
how to destroy america in three easy
steps um
and i want to talk to you about that
because i had a kind of a question for
you
so i'm thinking about writing a book
based on this and it's uh and it's about
destroying
a country uh that was founded on divine
principles with divine leadership with
with uh with leaders that are founding
fathers that were
you know are basically worshiped and
adored and uh and that book's called how
to destroy north korea in three easy
steps so
what would be the argument that you
could make against a disintegrationist
living in north korea as you call it
their forces between the unionists and
the disintegrationists it's very
interesting very provocative we can get
into it
but um but i think centrally is this
notion that there's
you know sort of a an attribute of the
united states that's
that's divine and i wonder if you can
comment on that and why couldn't another
country make the same kind of
divine claims to its origin and
therefore it shouldn't be disintegrated
when i
i believe i mean maybe controversial you
might want to get rid of north korea at
least in its current stand standing
yeah the north korean government can uh
can go that's that's all right with me
uh you know if we are if we're talking
about um you know the divine origins of
the united states what i would say is
that
uh the i don't think that the the
origins of the united states in terms of
the declaration of independence or the
constitution were written by
you know people who are quote-unquote
divinely inspired i think they were
built on thousands of years of
intellectual developments in the
judeo-christian west
and there are certain principles that
are embedded in the declaration of
independence that take their antecedents
obviously from those judeo-christian
values right when it says that
uh all men are created equal and down by
their creator a certain inalienable rise
these are all ideas that have a long
history in the west i actually talk
about this
more at length in my previous book right
side of history where i talk about sort
of the history of where a lot of these
enlightenment
ideas came from because i i think
there's a tendency particularly in
modern intellectual circles to draw a
complete gap between the enlightenment
and what came before
as though honestly like there was some
sort of divine
enlightenment that happened and it was
complete break with the past and that
that's not accurate i mean it's just not
accurate in any real historical or
intellectual sense
uh so the the divine inspiration for the
united states would have started a lot
earlier
and lay in the combination of greek
reason and
judeo-christian ethos that springs from
sinai um the the principles of the
united states are good because they
acknowledge human nature and because
uh they are deliberately constructed in
order to
effectuate the best parts of human
nature and tamp down the worst parts of
human nature that's that's why the
american system is good the american
system is
is self-justifying not because of any
appeal to divine authority it's it's
self-justifying because the principles
are indeed morally true and descriptive
of how human beings are and should
behave
when you look at that and you mention
you know kind of the intellectual
influence and mot
of modernity in terms of our scholars at
large and
one person that you uh reserve
particular ire for in this book is
howard zinn
who was deeply influenced of course by
noam chomsky who was a previous guest on
the show and
i thank you and i point out you know
i've had people cancel coming on my show
because i've had on you know dave rubin
or somebody like that
michael shermer uh but i've never had
yeah you or somebody cancel
uh coming on my show because i've had on
uh nom chomsky again i keep my show
you know politically free because i
think you other people do a great job
pod save america if you want to listen
to politics or
you can listen to the daily wire or
listen to ben shapiro show or what have
you
but um but you mentioned that and you
mentioned in the book howard zan and
noam chomsky
and i wonder you know thinking about it
what the
net effect of that has been on on on the
culture i mean we
you point out that many of our
departments not just you know history
departments on modern campuses
have this book howard zinn's a popular
history of the united states
which you know he was kind of i don't
know mutually influential on noam
chomsky
um and so i want to get your take is
that sort of irreversible i mean once
something reaches us
a level of popularity it becomes very
deeply entrenched
and now it's being read in high schools
etc so do you
what level of impact on these modern
intellectual circles do you think
that the relatively recent up um upsurge
of disintegrationist history of the
united states if you will
what effect do you think that's having
on on university culture
i mean tremendous effect obviously the
the sort of disintegrationist viewpoint
uh of howard's inn which is the united
states was never rooted in fundamentally
good principles that the united states
just like many other societies but
particularly evilly in the united states
was rooted
in hetero patriarchal racist cisgender
anti-woman nonsense uh that all of these
various interest groups uh were
competing for supremacy and white
supremacy lay at the root of the united
states
i mean you've seen this bleed into the
1619 project now you've seen howardson's
perspective
on american history which of course
begins with uh the arrival of
christopher columbus in the so-called
new world uh he begins his book
talking about the evils of christopher
columbus you've seen obviously the the
focus on tearing down columbus statues
around the united states in the middle
of this sort of
historical re-envisioning and rewriting
it's had a pretty deep impact again it
comes from a sort of marxist materialist
point of view which that the united
states is not in any way rooted in
principle
that all of the united states history is
really just cover
for exploitation and that the only
solution for exploitation is to tear
down those systems and put in place
quote unquote fairer more marxist
systems uh i think it's a complete
misread of american history i think that
it relies on an awful lot of the
lighting of evidence it's not posited as
a corrective to whitewashed history
which
i would kind of accept right i mean if
you're talking about american history
has historically been seen
into positive fashion right it ignored
too much the mistreatment of native
americans and black americans and women
that's totally fair if you want to talk
about how we can correct that that
history that's fine but if you want to
say
that the root of american history lies
in evil that is absolutely ignorant
and counter to prevailing evidence
because the fact is that
all of the things that we've talked
about right what that you're talking
about here you know racism and sexism
and bigotry and homophobia
all these things are present in nearly
every society in all of human history
what's different about the united states
is what's different about the united
states
and so focusing on the the evils of
humanity
as manifested in the united as unique to
the united states but all the good
things about the united states
as sort of universal to humanity runs
completely counter to all available
evidence
so given that and um you know your book
brainwashed which is about your
experiences and thoughts as a younger
person much younger person
as one was it might have been one of
your first books it was my first yeah
yeah
19 when i wrote it yeah yeah so um and
you talk about what the
university experience was like at ucla
of course it wasn't as
anywhere comparable to what you'd get at
uc san diego but nevertheless
if you were to create actually shapiro
university
what would that look like what would be
the required curriculum at shapiro
university
so i think obviously you'd have to
actually read some classics of western
literature and i think that would be
judged based on the importance
of the literature over the course of
history so it wouldn't be based on any
sort of
quota system for the race or sex of the
author i think that's
silliness of the highest order i think
that aristotle happens to be a more
important thinker than james baldwin
uh that is not a degradation to james
baldwin i think aristotle is more of an
important thing than nearly everybody
right
so you know pointing out that that you
only have a certain amount of time
uh a curriculum that included both of
those people would probably be a good
thing um but i think that
if you have to prioritize and you
prioritize the the most important
thoughts in human history
rather than prioritizing the sillinesses
of jacques derrida
or the ridiculousness of haiti monkeys
the
the attempt to quota your way to a good
education
is really really stupid because what's
inside your head matters much more
than the color of the skin on the
outside of your head so
sticking with the book theme your next
book i think was a book that you wrote
with your father
uh and involving of all subjects the
white sox
um so i want to ask you if you wrote a
book with your mother you talk you talk
a lot about your relationship with your
father but a little less so about your
mother
if you were to write a book with your
mother what would that be about
probably practical living my mom happens
to be the most practical person i know
like she's very touchless like she's
very down to earth
uh something needs to get done how do
you go about doing it and my dad tends
to be much more of a dreamer much more
kind of visionary in his
like he's the one who would talk
politics with me and my mom be the one
like okay now you gotta sit down and you
gotta do x y
and z how do we actually get that done
and so sort of making practical tips for
living would be
sort of more my mom's my mom's game and
also sort of along that theme in terms
of culture et cetera
within the you know shapiro university
universe uh
what would the role of you know cultural
things uh hollywood i always point out
you know the budget for hollywood
blockbuster movies about space or aliens
or whatever is like
10 times the budget of nasa and you know
why does it why does hollywood it's
actually if you take
how much you know hollywood contributes
to the gdp it's a lot i mean it's maybe
100 billion dollars or something like
that
it's pretty good but that's like what
apple has in cash you know
on a wednesday so why do you think
hollywood has such a big influence on
culture
and uh and then i'll ask a follow-up
just about uh
the influence that science that science
fiction has had on you in
in particular so uh obviously yeah as
you mentioned earlier attention is is
the key commodity so people spend an
awful lot of their time
being attentive to hollywood products
human beings are storytelling animals
and hollywood tell stories in a way that
not only is easy to to
comprehend uh unless it's the latest
nolan film apparently um but but also
uh in in a way that is somewhat
addictive i mean images tend to be
addictive to the human brain
in a way that words are not which is why
we are stupider culture now than we were
100 years ago or 150 years ago when
people tended to read a lot more often
it's also why people you know when they
watch the news tend to jump to
conclusions a lot more frequently than
actually
if they read the story um but that
that's yeah that's why hollywood is so
impactful
and it's why it matters the kind of
material that hollywood puts out there
as far as science fiction yeah i'm a
huge sci-fi fan i've always been a huge
sci-fi fan so i've read
i can't imagine the there's not much
classic sci-fi that i haven't read
um and uh there's some good news sci-fi
that's coming out ranging from from sort
of the action genre to sort of the more
um the more thinky sort of stuff um yeah
i
no i really enjoy sci-fi because again
it you can explore
both moral issues and technological
issues outside the confines of a lot of
the
dictates that that exist in normal
literature where
you know you can be you're not going to
be accused of
violating certain taboos uh if you're
writing in a theoretical universe as
opposed to
you know writing in practical one yeah i
think i've i had this conversation with
dave rubin in connection to the great
book fahrenheit 451 obviously relevant
to his book don't burn this book
um and directly relevant and we kind of
you know came to the conclusion that you
know science fiction allows you to kind
of
pre-game or have thought conduct thought
experiments as we physicists say
duncan experiments about the future in a
way that's really uh unique and
important and unusual
so i want to ask you if you were a
science fiction hero or if you were a
superhero dc comics fan
that you are uh what would be your
superpower what is your besides amazing
you know reducing your height a little
bit because you know
you don't get too tall that's right so
so what would be your your superpower
ben shapiro super power
oh if i could choose one or if i have
one right
we all know that your super power is you
know finishing a book in 35 seconds but
yeah
exactly i mean if i could choose one
obviously uh
physical and vulnerability would be a
pretty good one okay i feel like
superman style physical and
vulnerability would be a pretty good one
but yeah trying to think of other you
know super speed would probably be
pretty fun but i feel like that's just
like i feel like i can wait on a plane
and do some reading it's not that bad
[Music]
i've asked this to many people and i
kind of see a difference between how a
scientist answers this question and
non-scientists answer this question
if i could give you a pill one of my
sons is working on a pill called the
never dying pill
which will undoubtedly win him a nobel
prize ironically not his father
uh but if you could take a never dying
pill and only you
you can't you can't give it to everyone
you know uh would you take it
you know you'd be in the same health you
are now 35 or so years old
peak physical condition adonis like
physique would you take such a pill
i mean the only militating factors
against it would be uh
the wife and kids that's literally the
only militating factor against it but
yes i mean sure
uh uh because i just i'm fascinated by
people who uh
we get bored with the world this is a
pretty interesting place all right and
uh
there's always new stuff happening and
new things to find out so yeah i mean a
longer time span means more things i can
spend my attention on so yeah absolutely
actually so you know you are in harmony
with many scientists who want to see
what physical laws will
be like in the year 2200 but going ahead
just a few
more days a few fewer days than that i
want to ask you
uh first of all a lot of my friends you
know can't really vote for trump i mean
that's no surprise on the campus like
this i don't want to get
too political i don't get really
political at all but what do you say to
someone who can't vote for trump
and can't vote for biden and just kind
of in the middle what do they do
is it like flipping a coin what should
such a person do who's who's not like a
rabid political animal but just feels
like
we're in this we're in the zone right
now and neither one is particularly
palatable to them i mean
i hear you i didn't vote at the top of
the ticket last time around so i get it
i mean seriously like i i i don't think
that it's a moral failing not to vote or
to vote only
below the top of the ticket there's two
ways of viewing your vote right this is
what i said last time around
uh there is a way of viewing your vote
where it is just you know a coupon that
expires
tomorrow so you may as well use it
because who cares right it's burger king
coupon it goes away
uh the that after the election is
irrelevant uh or there is the idea that
your vote is
a is some sort of moral judgment upon
you
in which case you have to decide whether
that vote is actually a moral judgment
that's made about you
because you are giving the green lights
the character of the person whom you're
voting or because you are voting in
favor of the program the person stands
for
so if you believe that it's a referendum
on character you can vote that way
if you believe that it is a referendum
on the political program you can vote
that way
as well i tend to be pretty tolerant in
how people cast their votes because i
think that
there are a lot of fair arguments about
what a vote should represent um
but um being dissatisfied with the
current state of our politics i think
is is certainly not uh uncalled for
given
how things are going and uh speaking of
presidents until uh we're
about to get into the rapid fire section
of the conversation so if you thought
ben and i speak quickly
as it is wait till we go 8x uh on the
conversation in a minute if you have a
few more minutes ben is that okay
that's fine okay great so um i wonder
you know i felt like i feel like you are
you know critical of president obama i
mean you've you've been on the record of
critiquing him
and your feelings about him but i i
don't ask you about him specifically
uh but but more the meta question which
he was the first black president
it was a huge precedent for america and
i remember feeling like
we had turned a corner i wonder do you
think it's a good idea for a jew to be
president uh because
uh does it not you know carry with it
this unrealistic weight that the person
you know he or she would be a
representative of all the members of
that particular
you know in this case faith group so
honestly the reason i thought it would
be good for
america to have a black president would
be if the president had then
brought down the temperature in terms of
racial polarization which was sort of
the inherent promise and implicit
promise of the obama campaign it didn't
end up materializing
so as to whether a jew should be
president i don't care
i really don't i mean i don't care
whether a black person's present or jews
president i don't i don't care about any
of the
uh the features of the person who's
president other than you know their
character
and uh and what sort of policies they
effectuate
uh so do i think that it would be a
particularly bad thing for you to be
president
not especially i think how they
represent themselves as a jew matters to
me as a jew
right if you get somebody like bernie
sanders and he says i'm the first jewish
president and it's like okay yeah but
what do you do that is jewish
and his answer is i once had a matzo
ball like i i don't find that
particularly compelling in terms of
him being the quote-unquote first jewish
president so he's born ethnically jewish
whatever man um it says more about
america's willingness to elect
people of all different backgrounds
which says something good about
americans generally
but i i i've never expected you know
barack obama to be a stand-in for all
black americans or anything i always
expected barack obama
actually to be a rational individual and
i was disappointed when i thought that
he reverted to a certain level of tribal
politics
what do you think if president shapiro
came about
ben shapiro came about what would you
want to enact in your first 100 days in
office
uh well i would be the first president
in in modern american history to
completely destroy the executive branch
i mean
i i would i would eviscerate the
executive branch i'd fire nearly
everybody
and then i would force the uh and then
i'd force congress to pass very specific
laws dealing with what it was they
wanted to do as opposed to kicking all
legislative and policy-making priorities
over to the executive branch
um that would be i'd get rid of the
department of education uh and two other
departments that rick perry can't name
uh uh there there'd be there'd be a lot
of cuts a lot of cuts over at the uh
at the federal government level uh and i
think that is perfectly appropriate
um i i think that the president
basically has two jobs
one is to you know keep the nation safe
ensure that the laws are faithfully
executed
and the other is the educational job and
i would spend an awful lot of time
trying to educate the american public i
think about founding principles doing a
lot of the same things that i tried to
do on a daily basis just you know from
the seat of the
of the white house again this is one of
the divisions i've had about president
trump
i like a lot of his policy i think he's
done a terrible job on the educational
front trying to teach people what
government is what it should do and what
he expects of the country and what he
should do
uh so i i would i would spend a lot more
time on the second facet i think barack
obama spent a lot of time on that facet
he just
said things i disagree with um and he
grew the executive branch
massively but it's one of the reasons
why i don't really want to be president
because frankly i think i get to do a
lot of the fun stuff without having to
do a lot of the boring stuff
that's right yeah you'd uh you might
have a nicer
uh you know ride to show for you around
and uh called air force one
um so i want to ask you a couple
questions you're used to asking people
questions on the sunday special i was
honored to be on it a couple
about a year ago exactly um but i want
to ask you what's the one question you
wish you would be asked by somebody in
an interview show such as this
hmm um
i i suppose that i i wish that somebody
would ask me uh
whether i actually care about uh about
other individual human beings i like
that
because the perception is so wildly
different from what is the reality of
course you know when you're in politics
you spend a lot of time talking as you
should about broad public policy that
infuses you know all of that that
encompasses a lot of
individual human beings and and so you
have to make policy uh that is the best
for as many human beings
as humanly possible without violating
the rights of anybody um but
do i do i care about you know people who
are negatively affected by policies that
i talk about of course
i mean and and the basic notion in
politics is that
if i'm not directing a government policy
at helping
ex person it's because i don't care
about experts well maybe i do maybe i
think that the policy that i'm
effectuating is better for that person
or
maybe i think that there are
non-governmental things that can be done
to help that person that are more
important
than using the government as sort of a
broad club in order to achieve a
particular policy end
the government is a blunderbuss and i
think that most human interactions
are scalpel and ought to be done at that
level and follow-up to that is what's
the most
misunderstood thing about you other than
you're the president
of the simi valley cardi b fan club
the most misunderstood thing um
well i i think there's this weird
perception online
uh from people who've never watched the
show uh that i'm incredibly serious all
the time which means they've never
actually watched the show
uh and that's somewhat irritating to me
i mean the cardi b thing plays into it
that's a 10 minute long comedic segment
on my show uh and uh so there's
been this attempt by some folks on the
on the left to
you know paint me as some sort of
scolding personality who's just there to
to be you know angry at you all the time
and that's always weird i've never
really understood that frankly because i
think you watch one episode of the show
and you're not gonna get that
okay so let's move into the rapid fire
questions and for extra credit i urge
the audience to set the podcast on
2xspeed
uh so first of all um are you a
techno-optimist would you
sign up for a trip to mars or a
neurolink
chip to be embedded into your brain so
you can commune with the hazard
and uh like elon musk is having us do
would you would you accept such a chip
implanted into your brain or take a trip
to mars
uh how well-proven are the technologies
uh so far
not so good but if you got a letter from
from god and says you're not gonna die
in this trip to mars you might die on
mars but would you take the trip are you
an adventurous person in that sense yep
and would you take the chip and plant it
in your brain
uh what can it allow me to do
instantaneous recall
uh you can you know wrap like cardi b
anytime you want and you can
never necessarily i mean the latter
sounds terrible like that that would
cause a significant reduction in my
lingual abilities so i'm not super into
that but
uh but as far as uh instant recall and
all that uh
yeah no i think that i i'd probably i'd
probably do it i mean i i'm a techno
optimist i
i don't think the technology is
particularly threatening and i think
it's enhanced nearly every facet of
human life
i see you as sort of the most uh
optimistic pessimist that i know
but what are you really optimistic about
what kind of thing gives you optimism
for the future
human ability to solve problems so the
thing that we've apparently forgotten
completely about
and thus must take drastic action in
order to prevent uh the uh the
progressive abilities of human beings to
solve problems
it makes me absolutely nuts when you
know folks take climate change as an
example i i think climate change is
happening i think the evidence shows
climate change is happening i think the
majority of it is caused by human
activity
um but i am not of the belief that you
shut down all industry across the world
or tax it out of existence in order to
stop climate change i think human beings
have an unbelievably great ability to
adapt
and to create new products and services
it seems like so much of public life is
rooted in the assumption that human
beings are never going to be able to
create our way out of this one
which is a weird thing to say since
human beings have literally been
creating their way out of problems
for all of human history and that's
really accelerated in the last two to
three hundred years
when you look at that you look at the
progress though it comes with a downside
too and some say things like artificial
intelligence
will lead to kind of this dystopian
future where we're effectively going to
subvert you know all of our needs and to
machines and machine learning and
there'll be less
opportunities for employment etcetera
you talked to
andre yang about that um but the the
question i have for you now is like
what do you think about these kind of
ultimate extensions of that possibly
seeming like science fiction now
so-called simulation hypothesis that
we're actually the result
of a simulation being run on a you know
on a pentium processor
of the year you know 2700 that progress
that you talk about comes with a
downside crispr
gene modification all sorts of things
and in that way techno optimism
uh specifically can cause you know
potentially these dystopian scenarios
but i want to ask you specifically
have you heard of the simulation
hypothesis that we are effectively the
simulation
of this ultimate artificial intelligence
sometime in the future
uh i mean i've heard the hypothesis
there there's as there's there's
no evidence to back it so far as i'm
aware so it's as much of a faith
statement as a belief in god
with actually i would say maybe
significantly less evidence than the
idea of a
of a guy i mean it is just a form of a
god hypothesis just for in the different
guys it seems
um but um i mean given how crappy this
year has been maybe
that's right the simulation has a few
bugs we got to reboot it and i would ask
you know the simulators you know why
aren't
so many kardashians you know that's kind
of a question i would ask
um so you've already had me on your show
so who's your dream guest
in the in the future who would you most
like to have that's alive and then i'll
ask you dead but
first alive who who's who's like your
dream get or or
one of the two or three you don't have
to narrow it down but who
would you most like to have a
conversation with present company
excluded
that you haven't yet um well we've
been trying to book thomas soul for a
long time he's been a big hero of mine
um i would frankly i think it'd be
interesting to have a conversation with
barack obama excited quiz him on some
stuff i think he's an interesting
thinker i just think that he uh
i think that he dumbs down what he
actually thinks for for public
consumption a lot of the time
um and uh i would understand him not
being a too fond of the idea of getting
on camera with me giving some of the
things that i've said about his
presidency in the past
um the uh uh benjamin netanyahu prime
minister of israel we've tried to book
that i think we probably will sometime
this year
so yeah honestly there are a lot of
people who i like talking to i don't
think would make a great special
but are just interesting human beings
whose books i've read and usually that
happens on a one-off basis i read
somebody's book i think it's interesting
and then i want to talk to them
and very often i'll reach out to them on
one-on-one level and will actually have
conversations
that way and i tend to use them as sort
of expert resources on particular topics
so it may not sustain like a full
hour conversation the reason that you'd
want you know prominent figures is
because they have interesting life
histories and interesting stories to
tell
but in terms of exploration of ideas um
you know it's uh
i would say that i've had an opportunity
to talk with a lot of those people just
not all of it's public
right so uh next question revolves
around your social media presence
and that is the following uh you've got
3.1 million followers on twitter
um you've got millions of followers on
facebook online elsewhere
um but you know as i said to you in
person when we met uh about a year ago
i i said there's a famous vignette from
animal farm
where the the pig says to the donkey uh
benjamin your namesake
benjamin the donkey the pig says to the
donkey you've got such a nice tail
and i only have this short little curly
thing and the donkey says yeah the
god gave me the tail to keep away the
flies uh but i'd rather not have the
flies and not need the tail
so i guess my questions it could be
summarized you know if you could go time
traveling backwards
kill baby twitter uh you know would you
do it is there a downside to this to
this
to this statue that you've achieved um
well i mean there's certainly downsides
to to uh being
you know well-known uh and those
downsides range from safety concerns to
taking enormous amounts of abuse every
three weeks when i turn on twitter and
it's literally on the dot every three
weeks
i know what's going on with their
algorithm or maybe i just say something
dumb every three weeks
whichever um but in any case uh that you
know there are obviously downsides to it
um i think of all the apps twitter is
the most damaging because twitter uh
is built for one-liners and then it went
from a place where everybody sort of
joked and understood it was built for
one-liners to a place where you were
supposed to perform serious discourse in
one-liners which is not possible
uh so i think what it started off as and
what it morphed in what it started off
as was fine and basically innocuous
and what it morphed into is something
that's really really damaging especially
now that it's like okay we're going to
go back to 2011
and we're going to dig up a joke tweet
that you sent and we're going to destroy
you and that's for everybody right
we're going to completely pretend that
what was essentially a
repository for making dumb jokes was
actually the same as it is now which is
vetted political statements being put
out in 240 character increments
right and that that's that's very silly
um
twitter is the most dangerous of them um
yeah i i think
pretty much obviously i've had people
cancel you know
unfollow me unfriend me whatever because
i was on your show um
and i think that kind of you know belies
a certain type of simple-mindedness uh
you know i'm not inviting
everybody to unfollow et cetera but i do
think it has had a pernicious effect
on the culture it's almost become a part
of almost hollywood silicon valley kind
of
nexus of influence that's so outsized i
want to go to a positive
thing right now uh why do you why do you
play the violin
what uh what does that mean to you is it
something that you feel god's presence
the most you know oftentimes i ask
people
where do you feel god's oh when my child
was born i'm like okay well that was
once or you know if you're lucky more
than once or even if you're lucky once a
lot of people can't experience do you
feel god's presence through music
um through listening more than playing
because i hear my own flaws when i play
i just uh as in every part of my job um
when whenever i do something i tend to
be my own
toughest critic and so i tend to hear
the parts where i'm playing that don't
sound as good as they should
um but uh i mean i play because i've
been playing since i was five and i
enjoy making music with my father and
it's
he he plays piano he's a professional
pianist and so he can play brahms
together
and uh and that's wonderful and
enjoyable my kids really
love it and when you're really into it
it's you know you feel a certain flow
a psychological flow that's that's quite
good for you mentally where where i see
god the most in my life is is obviously
my kids uh and it's not just in their
birth it's how they act it's how they
see the world it's how they
interact with each other um and uh
spending a shabbat and watching them
play on the floor with each other is
pretty much as close to heaven as i
think you're gonna get in this lifetime
yeah i always say kids are the only
proven form of time travel it's just
you don't get to go with them into the
deep future but they're you carry their
meat out or shaped by you
and that actually will live onto the
future all right that brings us to the
very end
questions there's just three left to go
ben first question i ask all my guests
i'm going to ask you
can you provide for us in you know 30
seconds or less a geometric quantization
of space and time that also involves
relativistic
uh properties of the hadron particles
42 right
i've asked nobel prize winners they
can't get that okay so
as you know in judaism there's a concept
of what's called an ethical will a zava
ah
and and that's sort of a bequeathing of
one's
ethical and wisdom values rather than
their monetary
acquisitions or material acquisitions
and
uh i know those will all go to uh to uh
you know good causes i'm sure but
but in this case i want to know what
would be in your zava on your ethical
will
what kinds of wisdom or morals you want
to leave to your children and
and those of us or those out there who
are your ideological children in a sense
uh well i mean the the the sukkah the
verses from deuteronomy where it
describes
uh choosing life and that the choice is
in your hands that's just that's partial
very good that's my best yeah
to me the key aspect of human living is
recognizing that
most choice about your own life is in
your hands doesn't mean everything
obviously health is not in your hands in
many cases and
and sometimes wealth um but uh most of
the choices that you make
toward happiness or non-happiness in
your life are in your own hands and that
that comes with an
awful you know a lot of responsibility
but also an awful lot of freedom
and those two are balanced the freedom
and the responsibility are balanced i
think as a society we've tried to
maximize the freedom and reduce the
responsibility
but i don't think you can do that i
think they're two sides of the same coin
the more you want to be free
the more you have to take responsibility
for your decisions and conversely the
more responsibility you take on your
shoulders the more free you are to
actually
act within your own life okay great i
want to ask you about uh
going also into the future and sort of a
time capsule question but first a word
from our sponsors
which is cardi b rap microphones
courtesy no no
i actually don't have any sponsors and i
likely won't after this interview which
is this bucket and this mob
sponsored by cardi b okay hey we're not
gonna get uh we're not gonna get into
that aspect of the culture very good ben
okay uh next question involves science
fiction
and so the into the impossible podcast
is named after one of sir arthur c
clarke's uh famous three laws the first
one being
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
the second one being for every expert
there's an equal and opposite
expert but the third one is the only way
to find out uh what is possible
is to venture a little bit into the
impossible so now going backwards in
time i want to ask you
what thing or achievement or whatever
seemed impossible to a young ben shapiro
20 year old ben shapiro
but now since you had the courage which
i think is one of your dominant traits
you have an incredible amount of courage
you went into the impossible and you did
it so what thing in the past would you
tell yourself
have this courage go forward what seems
impossible will become possible
honestly i i think that the the one
thing that i would tell myself as a
young person
uh is is i i've never had uh uh i've
never been shy
so that was never something i had to
advise myself to shirk uh with the
shyness
uh to me it would be uh have the courage
to question your own assumptions and
your own opinions
uh and don't be quite so sure of what it
is that you're saying and take a look at
all sides i hope that's something i've
gotten better at
over the course of my career and i hope
that people can you know if you listen
to the show but or if you read my
writings
you can hear me kind of turning over
points before i immediately come to a
conclusion
okay couple more rapid fire would you
rather win a nobel peace prize or a
pulitzer prize
just quick answers oh god they're so
degraded honestly i'd rather have a five
dollar cup of coffee than either
okay good um so would you rather write a
torah commentary or a talmud commentary
or commentary and uh what would you say
to uh like hillel said uh you know the
secret to torah is secret to the torah
is
is uh don't do something unpleasant to
your neighbor that you find
unpleasant yourself what's kind of your
teaching or conversion on one leg so to
speak
uh i i think i've already said it uh
that your life is in your hands and so
make choices that are most likely to
maximize success for yourself and for
those you care about
very good okay ben shapiro well last
question if you'll indulge me ten more
seconds
let's say daily wire goes off the air
the internet gets zapped
uh you have to start all over what what
would you do you have no twitter no
facebook i mean it'd be like a paradise
apparently what would you do differently
besides you know maybe learning to code
or
or whatever you guys would do um i don't
know um i mean i i enjoy my life so much
i get to speak about topics i care about
and write about topics i care about so
uh if if all that went away i'd go back
to what i was doing before which was
doing all that anonymously right
before i was famous doing this stuff i
was not famous doing this stuff so i
would continue
and to do a lot of that stuff or maybe
i'd go to medical school
my wife seems to honestly it seems kind
of cool yeah okay ben uh your favorite
day of the year i asked you last year
when i was on your show
turn the tables around i asked you
what's your favorite day of the year
it's yom kippur
i want to wish you a very meaningful yom
kippur rosh hashanah
high holidays and a happy new year to
you and your family and thank you for
all the
wonderful uh influence you've had on the
world to the good which i think is very
very important so thank you ben
shanatova jonathan thanks so much
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
at imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes